okay so russell wilson threw his agent
on the record last week
said russell's yet to request a trade
he wants to stay in seattle but in the
event in the event that the seahawks
would decide just on their own to trade
one of the best quarterbacks in football
to another team
russell would accept a trade to four
teams cowboys
saints bears and the raiders
and that's fascinating to me because
david carr number one overall pick of
the houston texans back in 2002 their
first year of existence and also the
older brother
of derrick carr the current starting
quarterback of the las vegas raiders
wrote an article that was posted today
by nfl.com
listing the top 10 quarterbacks that can
be acquired this year by free agency
trade or the draft at number two behind
desean watson the current texans
quarterback is russell wilson
and one of the quotes from the david
carr
brother of derek carr article is
if i'm one of those four teams i.e
the raiders cowboys bears saints i'm
picking up the phone
yesterday he russell wilson is
everything you want in a quarterback
with endless talent arm strength poison
intelligence plus he has the kind of ice
in his veins that gives his team a
chance to win
late in games no matter how great the
deficit he'll cost a great deal but the
on-field production and leadership you'd
get in return would be worth it
did i mention that david carr's brother
is the starting quarterback of the las
vegas raiders
what in the hell is going on here i was
stunned
especially because 2018
the last year and perhaps the only year
that david carr
ranked quarterbacks in the off season he
had his brother derek ahead of russell
wilson
and guess what mike derek carr is known
for blocking
people on twitter so i haven't checked
lately to see if he has
blocked his brother on twitter but i
think that might be coming once he sees
this yeah it was uh
kind of weird that that he would put the
raiders in that list
considering his brother is the starting
quarterback we think
of the raiders and starting quarterback
of the raiders perhaps in 2021 or
perhaps not who knows maybe he knows
something we don't know mike but it was
very strange to
to see david carr write that and i'm
sure it's a difficult position sometimes
that he's in because his brother is a
starting quarterback the raiders but
still
just a strange thing to to say when your
brother is the starting quarterback of
the raiders
superficial analysis of the situation it
is fair
and honest and objective analysis by
david carr of the situation even if it's
his brother
who gets thrown overboard he's willing
to say what he
genuinely believes blocked by his
brother or
wtf text messages from his brother be
damned
now next level cynical analysis and this
is something sims suggested and
i'm sure he'll speak his piece about it
tomorrow morning on pft live
what if this is something that dairy
david
and derek communicated about ahead of
time and derek said go ahead and do it
because i'm sick of this crap
i'm sick of this constant speculation
i'm sick of them never coming out and
saying i'm the guy
i'm sick of them not giving me an
extension i'm sick of them saying we're
constantly looking for an upgrade
because mike mayok has said that at
least once a year for the last
two or three years ever since mayhawk
became the gm remember they looked at
dwayne haskins and kyler murray
going into the 2019 draft why because
they're always looking for an upgraded
quarterback
even at quarterback there's no sacred
cows and i think derek carr may be sick
of it that's
that's sims argument and there may be
some merit to that
that derek's just had enough you know if
this is if you're gonna play this game
if you're gonna come out and shoot this
down
because if i'm if i'm derek carr
and russell wilson through his agent
targets my job i want my team to come
out and say
we're not doing it now the reality is
he's russell wilson and that may
again that may be the truth david carr
realizes it's russell wilson but it was
just three years ago
that david carr assessed his brother's
skills as being greater than russell
wilson so something weird is going on
here
yeah something very weird is going on
here mike and frankly russell wilson is
an upgrade
over derek carr when you consider that
derek carr has done nothing in the
postseason he missed the postseason game
that he could have played and he was
hurt
when they played the texans so you know
he hasn't done anything in the
postseason to let you say
this guy's going to lead us to a super
bowl 2016 was his best season he went
12-3 as a starter he's a three-time pro
bowler but
when you just look over the last couple
of years the last
four years frankly he was mvp candidate
in 2016 in the last four years
he hasn't done very much yes he's gotten
more mvp votes than russell wilson ever
has because i think he got
some in 2016 when he had the great
season but
having said that russell wilson i think
we'd all agree
including david carr is the better
quarterback
yep absolutely and again i i feel like
something is brewing behind the scenes
and who knows maybe the raiders
are putting together a package to try to
get russell wilson maybe the saints are
maybe the bears are the only team that i
don't think is doing it is the cowboys
because
you can't trade dak prescott as a
practical matter you'd have to let dak
prescott walk away and get compensatory
draft pick consideration next year i
just think it'd be too hard with
everything you have to give up
to put a competitive team around russell
wilson if you make
that move hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports